[Music]
kelly clarkson gets emotional addressing
gun violence at the 2018 Billboard Music
Awards this is gonna be so hard
once again y'all were grieving for more
kids that have died for just an absolute
no reason at all
the 36 year old singer who hosted the
show started the night with tears in her
eyes asking for change after 10 people
were killed and 13 were injured during a
shooting at Santa Fe High School in
Texas obviously we want to pray for all
the victims you want to pray for their
families but I'm so sick of moment of
silence like it's not working instead at
Kelly urged the audience to push for
stricter gun control in their
communities
I can't imagine I four children I cannot
imagine getting that phone call or that
knock on the door we need to do better
so people are failing our children so I
want to respect them and honor them with
tonight y'all let's in your community
where you live your friends everybody
let's have a moment of action
[Applause]
[Music]